cet aquarium géant d'un hôtel de Berlin
a exploser des versions plus d'un
million de litres d'eau on te raconte ce
qu'il s'est passé alors cet aquarium
cylindrique il mesure une quinzaine de
mètres de haut et contient environ 1500
poissons tropicaux il se trouve au
rez-de-chaussée de l'hôtel Radisson Blu
un hôtel 5 étoiles de Berlin ce vendredi
16 décembre vers 5h50 du matin les
parois de verre ont commencé à éclater
pour des raisons encore indéterminées
selon la police allemande qui a précisé
qu'il ne s'agissait pas d'une fissure
l'aquarium a éclaté deux personnes ont
été blessées par des éclats de verre et
ont dû être transportés à l'hôpital les
autorités sont également à la recherche
de personnes sous les débris même si
rien indique formellement qu'il y en est
une grande partie des 1500 poissons
tropicaux sont morts mais on ne sait pas
combien exactement encore pour le moment
les pompiers évoquent cependant des
dommages marins incroyables en plus
d'avoir détruit le rez-de-chaussée de
l'hôtel une extrême quantité d'eau c'est
également déversée sur la route bloquant
une partie de la circulation les 350
résidents de l'hôtel ont également dû
être relogées
[Musique]